i saw a tweet this weekend i don't know
if you have uh-oh um
from joel klatt actually
someone uh tweeted to him saying like
what's the best story about you and
the story he told tweeted out made me
want to ask you what happened so
the story that he was talking about was
saying how you got into a skirmish
outside a local establishment one night
and that you kicked someone in the jaw
and that all you could think about was
how you got your
leg that high and i was just wondering
is what happened now this is the tweet
that joel sent it yeah
um
yeah he's talking about i think because
you know he's like the face of fox now
so he does q a before the big games i
think some person was like give us your
best friend and shop story
so cloud used to be a wild man and then
he played uh i think triple a or single
a baseball did that and then came back
to college so he was like 26 and we're
like 21 is weird real athlete and then
and then yeah and then he real smart too
it's basically like having a coach as a
player was weird he like judges free
drinking [ __ ] but um
we got a party bus and went downtown so
it's klopp me joel clatt some other guys
and uh we're out drinking you know i'm
21. i just turned 21
and we were walking down near uh 16th
street mall we were walking on some bar
and i was drinking jameson
and uh we're all pretty tipsy and
there's a group of russians talking [ __ ]
to a group of armenians but we're in the
middle but we weren't paying attention
so i thought the russians were talking
to us talking [ __ ] to us it was like
sick russians but they weren't they were
talking over us to like we just haven't
been walking by so i thought they were
talking [ __ ] to us
so and you're 21 at this 21. yeah yeah
and so uh a fight ensued with these
russians and copping clotter like what
the [ __ ] there's no fight what is he
doing where is he fighting these guys
and i thought it was chaos there it is
let's hear a good brent shop story he
got a skirmish skirmish
quote squirmish outside a local station
when i kicked the dude in the jaw i just
remember thinking how did brian get his
legs so high i had jeans on and boots on
and
i didn't know you could kick back then
but you did take taekwondo
uh not really i mean
yeah you know not really my dad made us
but it's lame but uh so i thought all of
us were fighting i thought it was this
was the russians so i thought
everybody's fighting but they weren't
they were standing back on what are you
doing and i was so hammered i thought
everybody's fighting so these russians
came at me
and i you know i'm hitting these
russians and they're falling down and
then one just ran straight at me i
remember thinking what the [ __ ] is he
doing and remember at the time i was
like balls deep into pride fighting with
crow cop and fedor and before we left
that morning i watched uh fedor and
krokop fight and like the highlights of
fedor like knocking out all these guys
like van der ley with head cakes so that
must been in my like you know just in my
subconscious mind so when this russian
rant me i just in my [ __ ]
levi jeans and boots i head kicked this
russian knocked him out
that's why in copper and then cops like
i'm married clapper clap graham and goes
run because the co we could hear the
cops because i [ __ ] these guys how
much did you weigh them you were huge
two four no 240. that's big
football how small you all kind of small
she's like 190 but in shape klopp was
the biggest 40s that's that's not an
average size first for football players
whatever you're 21. but then i remember
like i remember the russian pulled out a
knife on clock and klopp grabbed his
hand and crushed it like like i just
remember clap grabbing it like get out
of the way and then like this and then
squeezing this kid's hand so you know
they were they must been they were older
than us i remember crop crushing his
[ __ ] hand to let the knife go and
clap grabbed the knife and just chucked
it
jesus christ i remember they're like you
better run i was like why we're all in
fights like just you are you idiot like
what
and clap i bet cloud can say he has a
picture the next morning i stayed crap
we crashed at this [ __ ] a hotel but i
was getting about i had an impala back
then old school impala and here's a
picture of me when we got dropped off
from party bus in uh boulder because i
kicked that guy ripped my jeans because
i kicked so high i ripped my jeans but i
knocked him out and here's a picture of
me like just my hair i have long curly
hair i just like pure death getting into
my car i was like wait wait that's the
picture
i got to see that picture that's what
clad is talking about there [ __ ]